the report yesterday maybe more
importantly than anything it totally
exonerates me the end result was wrong I
mean there was total bias I mean when
you look at Peter struck and what he
said about me
when you look at comeö let's move so I
guess you know his interests he was a
pretty good report and then I say that
the IG blew it at the very end with that
statement Peter struck should have been
fired a long time ago and others
shouldn't the top people were horrible
you look at what happened they were
plotting against my election this report
contains no evidence to make any
reasonable person conclude that the
Special Counsel investigation is
anything other than independent
impartial and just as important today as
it was before this report was issued was
a bit surreal today the president
walking out on the North Lawn there an
interview live on Fox and Friends and
then holding a gaggle with the press
it's the first time ever that that has
happened with the President of the
United States and he made a lot of news
today let's bring in our panel joining
me here at Shinnecock Hills my
colleagues Bill Hemmer co-host of
America's newsroom here on Fox News
Channel now three hours and Melissa
Francis co-host of after the bell on Fox
Business Network in Washington Molly
Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and in New York Bill McGurn
mainstream columnist for The Wall Street
Journal welcome all bill that happened
right after you were hour and it was
continually over our that site I thought
it was quite remarkable and I I thought
about the juxtaposition between meeting
with Chairman Kim on Tuesday and then
walking on the North Lawn as he did
earlier today it was my sense Pratt when
he became president that he was the one
who was going to run his communications
department that he was going to be his
press secretary not literally but
figuratively as commander in chief and
the Mullen matter kind of took that took
that club out of his bag so to speak
nicely done
thank you and set that to the side for
now and with the economy moving the way
it is I think with the Korea the
Singapore summit behind him with the IG
report yesterday my sense watching it
live was here was a president who feels
berated yet again because I believe he
would much rather hold a press
conference once a week if his lawyers up
to this point had allowed him yeah Molly
there's a lot of low-hanging fruit in
this IG report if you're a trump
supporter in the Trump administration I
think there were a lot of people I
talked to who said they were
disappointed with the characterization
that it was a nothing burger from the
star yeah I read all 568 pages and I
have the lack of sleep to prove it Chuck
Schumer is absolutely wrong that about
what he said about this report it was an
exhaustive detailed look at widespread
corruption bias poor judgment
bad decision-making throughout the FBI
well as focused on that Comey on the
Clinton probe but of course the same
people were involved in the Clinton
probe as were involved in what has now
become the Special Counsel and when you
look at what these people were saying
how they were openly conspiring against
Donald Trump's election how they were
fantasizing about his impeachment after
the election and there is I mean that
really calls into question what's going
on with the entire basis of the Moller
probe particularly as now a year and a
half into this we have no evidence of
treasonous collusion with Russia and a
lot of evidence of bad behavior by the
FBI will obviously see if there was
another IG report to come the other news
made today was about China take a listen
to what the president said in China's
reaction well we're just going to do 50
billion dollars on 50 billion dollars of
high technology equipment and other
things coming into the country because
so much of our secrets you know we have
the great brain power in Silicon Valley
and China and others steal those secrets
if the u.s. takes unilateral and
protectionist measures that harm China's
interests we will immediately respond
and take necessary measures to defend
our legitimate rights and interests
Melissa what are we looking at here I
mean is this heading down the road of a
trade war I think all you have to do is
look at the markets to
see where it's headed and that's markets
went down right away on this news by the
end of the day they clawed their way
back to still down but well up the lows
of the session there's one thing to keep
in mind when you're listening to all
this chatter about a trade war there was
a moment at the g7 when President Trump
said hey why don't we all drop all of
our tariffs on everything and it went
over like a lead balloon
everyone just stepped back there was no
response that's where he's headed he
understands that no tariffs are best for
consumers and workers a true free market
but we haven't had that for a long time
and he's gonna continue to use both the
carrot and the stick to get closer to
that but that's the truth of the matter
when he said that it was revealed that
he doesn't believe in tariffs he
believes in no tariffs but he knows it's
gonna take a lot to push other countries
there well how does that play on Main
Street well I don't know whether main
three likes us look the Chinese are
guilty of some bad behavior I'd like to
see a few more carrots rather than the
sticks I too was heartened by the no
tariffs kind of called the president
made but if you were serious about that
I think what he should do is look he
doesn't like multilateral agreements
right negotiate with the partner like
Britain or even Canada a bilateral deal
that has no tariffs like find a partner
that has very few trade issues with us
negotiate the ideal bilateral and then
say this deal is open to anyone else who
wants the same terms I I think that's a
more effective way of doing it and it's
more with the carrot than the stick all
right let's talk immigration here's what
the president said about that this
morning and some reaction I'm looking at
both of them I certainly wouldn't assign
them Oman what is the bill I mean I need
a bill that gives this country
tremendous border security I have to
have that we have to get believes I mean
the wall we have to have the world we
don't have the wall there's no bill now
we are waiting the president
four pillars our deal is deal and the
president asked this house to act
everybody says to the public yes we want
to work in a bipartisan way well you
have the opportunity to do it and you
have retreated there's some heart
failure on Capitol Hill today and the
White House put out a statement this
afternoon the president fully supports
both the Goodlatte bill and the house
leadership bill in this morning's
interview he was commenting on the
discharge petition in the house not the
new package he would sign either the
good lad or the leadership bills so
straightening that out bill important
clarification I have half an eye on you
know a midterm election that's five
months from now it's my sense that none
of this moves until then perhaps you
know depending on the outcome in
November you get a little more moving on
this but I think the talk right now is
just that that the house is one thing
sent it's a whole different ballgame and
they're looking at balance of power and
I think that's that's where this
attention Bolly him saying originally
that he wouldn't sign the moderate bill
made sense why give up leverage when you
have it right now the walk back from the
White House was curious and they're
saying that this does have the four
pillars that Trump sought except it
really does water down chain migration
restrictions that were a big part of
Trump's goals and it also expands the
amnesty in a way that is really
dangerous and how much people who are
children of temporary foreign workers
would be able to apply for amnesty
that's a really uncontrolled program
there and I think that the White House
should think a lot about whether they
really truly are on board with this or
whether they're giving up way too much
and losing their leverage you know bill
both sides are saying the other side is
preventing them from getting the bill
across the finish line how does this
play to Bill's point here it seems like
it may push past election day yeah I
think that's been the history look I'm
old enough to remember I was in the Bush
administration when the bipartisan deal
fell apart it's very hard to get
immigration through I think some people
would rather have the issue than have it
resolved there should be a pretty easy
path at least on on daca or something to
give the president in his wall which
he's not going to back down on
in exchange for some of the things
Democrats want on Daka so it's it's kind
of sad because we're not gonna get
anywhere until we start taking this
apart piece by piece
last thing where we began I mean he took
over the news cycle he owned the day by
that hour on the North Lawn can you
imagine any other president doing that
you made the point earlier today that it
hasn't happened it is that astounding
that is the kind of presidency we're
gonna happen have and you look at the
reporters went wild you know they sort
of they looked like a frenzied team of I
don't know what you know
yapping puppies something others said
that he looked like the crazy one it was
definitely an unusual scene filled the
day yeah